- good afternoon everybody
I'm morning evening wherever you may be
this is ethan klein host of the world's
most prolific podcast the most serious
and fantastic podcast we have with us
baby yoda famous the new Star Wars show
so sweet little Alfredo mmm
ela how are you today I'm good thank you
thank you for the update today's episode
is sponsored by quip and door - later
today we have the shoenice on the
podcast it's happening folks after the
break shoenice will be joining us the
one and only the ultimate slammer the
grand slammer the alcohol slammer he's
hit his head many times we learned and
slammer of his head it's all happening
was shoenice ready to go yeah okay yeah
well speaking of slamming let me show
you this video this I couldn't stop
laughing at now I'm assuming this
happened in China or like where I've
seen Pete someone pull this move before
where they take a dump and then they
just let it fall to the ground through
their pants like how do use that
maneuver even work because here watch
this guy you see I just dropped some
turd out of his pants
he's like Shawshank Redemption like a
prisoner you know dropping dirt so you
kind of told her story where you pooped
your pants into Vegas no but this guy
those were like solid nuggies like that
was premeditated I had an accident where
[ __ ] slid down my those are solid nugs
dude look at it that guy just [ __ ] his
pants like straight up while walking I
mean what do you guys think that that's
a premeditated nuggie drop yeah is that
your animal there's but no wiping and
you know if you're when you're walking
that shit's got to get smashed between
your cheeks like tryin to play it off
like
he's on the phone yes so now I noticed
hello he's on the phone yeah hey nobody
expects anything from someone on the
phone well here's the best part that's
not the best part
so homie believes a little [ __ ] bomb on
the floor that's bored and then this
dude's just going about his day just
thinking myself try a trikes try to
understand that dude in human [ __ ] is so
good for you I can't move now this looks
like China I mean just cuz everyone
looks Asian and I feel like that's
something that would happen in China if
I can if I may say so just like you look
ya'll Oh what did I slip on and then
you're like it's human [ __ ] you never
expect that there would be human [ __ ]
bro where to go is that the best yeah I
love that man I had a good time watching
that dude
moving on we've got a lot of good videos
here to start the day off get warmed up
for Shu nights
Kidz Bop mom have you seen this this is
a somewhat viral clip wait stars well
tell me what you think of this lady
she thinks it's cute that her driver
almost hit my kids and she thinks she
needs to take a video of it instead of
apologizing like a state being in the
middle that bro is gonna help you being
a [ __ ] is gonna help calm down calm
down what I'd like you to do is
apologize instead of being a [ __ ]
you're calling it sorry but you're
calling it [ __ ] I'll set an example
sorry my kids guy heard me calling you a
[ __ ] your windows open it can't hear me
because they're listening to Kidz Bop
explain that cuz on one hand she's it
feels like she's doing shtick like my
kids yeah like she's doing a [ __ ] what
my kids can't hear me cuz I listening to
kpop Kidz Bop like but she's I don't
know this is she's kind of scary but
kind of funny
mm-hm so weird one shoenice what I'd
like you to do is apologize instead of
being a [ __ ]
you're coming sorry but you're calling
me a [ __ ] I'll set an example sorry
like she's doing acts yeah he's putting
on schtick yeah that's what I don't get
she trying to make fun of her worth like
it sounds like a valley girl you're
sorry but you're calling it [ __ ] she
doesn't example
my kids guy heard me calling you a [ __ ]
your windows open they can't hear me
because they're listening to kidsbox
like why would you fake you know what I
mean it's too funny might be fake kids
pop and then what does she say after
here's the problem with YouTube today
yeah oh here's the source oh this
originated on image or how's that
possible here's a problem with you -
zoinks this video only has 2 million
views if this was posted 15 years ago
this video would have 150 million but
the algorithm we don't get the love for
these viral videos anymore mm-hmm kids
Bob Karen it's called hello that's got
all the recipe all the necessary
ingredients for a mega viral head and we
don't get to enjoy these on them on a
humanity scale where kids Bob Karen
isn't part of the comment vernacular and
I think that's a goddamn shame that
YouTube needs to address this [ __ ] I
don't feel like it's fake do you really
I don't know but how is she real mmm I'm
sure nice real shame this is realer than
as real as it gets
it says this happened to a friend of
mine in New York City it's a wild ride
start to finish the back story is she
was in a lift ride in New York City and
the driver cut someone off and Karen
lost it kids Bob Karen can you play with
us she said in I think it's a goddamn
shame that everyone in America hasn't
seen this open they can't hear me
because they're listening to kidsbox
attitude gratitude sucks dick
that was awesome though I feel like my
parents would enjoy that
like why is YouTube not showing that to
my parents I saw in the same video on
Twitter and has six million views that
okay so so why is you do see what the
shame is up in the ball yeah why are we
getting viral clips on Twitter can you
try to find it on Facebook they're like
well it's only one minute so we're not
promoting one minute exactly right yeah
that's exactly what's happening and
there's cursing in it they're like we'll
[ __ ] that all right we can't make money
from it either so obviously we're not
gonna show it to anyone you know I'll
try to find out on Facebook I bet it has
like a billion views meanwhile Facebook
doesn't give a [ __ ] they're monetizing
like Russian propaganda they're like
monetizing Isis videos over on Facebook
I don't give a [ __ ] they're like did you
ever dream of a better life
join beautiful Isis actually speaking of
Isis there's this great story of a girl
an American girl she went to join Isis
got married to an Isis fighter had a
baby and now she wants to move back to
America and and then that a judge
whoever cuts our case said she's not
American anymore her citizenship is gone
when she went and joined Isis and she's
all crying like dude I didn't know what
I was doing I just wanted to join Isis
and death to America and I just I really
just wanted to find a better life for my
family and Isis where we decapitate
people on the weekends
my husband died he was hung for not
loving a Mohammed more it was like calm
down my kids are listening to kids Bob
[Music]
Zak is going deep deep deep into the
meme holder she was doing all this Isis
propaganda about death to America and
stuff before she moved there she was
encouraging people to do terrorist
attacks in America
and now she wants to come back what
happened to Isis dude weird how do you
go from living in America to Isis I
don't know she was radicalized online
they say but I don't know that happened
a lot to people in Europe and the UK to
who they leave to go join Isis and then
they want to come back when it didn't
work out the ISIS thing it didn't really
work out can I come back to civilization
now no [ __ ] you snowman you stay in the
desert I love that it's like a full-on
Justice boner um guys there is so much
happening at Popeye's there's actually
now a subreddit called Popeyes freak out
that is fairly dedicated to sub Popeyes
Popeyes violets and freak-outs
I say again as a subreddit Popeyes freak
out
that is dedicated solely to the violence
and freak outs over Popeyes and they
have tons of submissions there's so much
content going on it's a it's not just a
coincidence there is a phenomenon a
Popeye's of people fighting and beefing
and die what are they putting in the
food because I feel like something
doesn't make sense you know could be
government experimenting on no certainly
could be they're doing some chemical
experiments that they want jaw drop on
like rural areas of enemy states to make
them all just go crazy well here's a new
one the employees get into a brawl now
at Popeyes it's not even the customers
that's what I'm saying there's something
in the food it's just all now for all
over a Popeyes dude yeah
throwing punches look how many workers
there take it off the screen because I
it gets it's just a little too violent
but let's hear the audio we good yeah
you're good I'll just describe the man I
think there's like five girls just
slapping and punching they got that
Popeyes chicken sandwich coursing
through their veins damn it's like
steroids they call that roid rage that
go that Popeyes rage right that's that's
what I'm saying then how is there's so
many employees it's like a tiny little
Popeyes they move a lot of chicken you
don't see fights at KFC
you never saw fights at KFC you never
saw fights at chick-fil-a why is Popeyes
what is going on at Popeyes there are a
lot of fights at McDonald's I want to
point out well yeah that's kind of its
own sub-genre videos channel brawls yeah
we haven't delved into that much on the
podcast but I've been a connoisseur of
the McDonald's brawl video there for a
while yeah I could curate some for you
what was the like Paul fired the
character mm-hm he was a fighter you see
it spinach right on anyone get off yeah
he was a fighter that is super
interesting Wow I think they're I think
they're doing civilian testing and
instead of going to war they just
dropped chicken sandwiches over Iraq and
the civilian population goes ballistic
and turns on each other yeah it says
don't be uprising it makes more sense
than what I'm saying in front of me Zach
says I didn't like the sandwich you
didn't like Zach why don't you talk
first of all I didn't I didn't like
sandwiches that's that's so weird cuz
you like that's like everything it was
so plain but did you try the spicy one
yeah you didn't like it
no I danced for that Sam yeah I just
didn't like it weird
did you get the urge to like to strangle
anybody no else is there were no fights
in
the one you went to right there was no
one there I think you went to like a
bootleg
I won't say where you went but yeah you
told me and it was a pretty bougie
neighborhood I think you might need to
predominantly white area yes
so those guys don't know how to make the
chicken you gotta go to Lex you got to
go to Central LA yeah LaBrea
I got I got two of them and it was soggy
and yeah that's not because there's
nobody there buying the train you got to
get a fresh who was the worker white no
oh the worker was black yes interesting
can we not make it about race Dan once
again brought it up I'm following his
cue okay I'm just saying this is a
conversation about chicken we have to be
really tasty food he went to a Popeyes
and like a couple of conspiracies Ali
there's there there's not many black
people out in that area no almost not
yeah and the chicken incidentally is
also horrible so guess what they also
don't know how to make tasty chicken but
this could be like white people do is
Valley people could be like a conspiracy
calm down I don't know why we have to
keep making this about race though I
didn't and we already got in trouble
about it
am I being not woke right now I don't
know I would like you to wake up
no I'm I'm slept I'm sleeping about but
I don't know I I would challenge you to
go to a Popeyes in the more inner-city
areas AK and do a and let me know if
that one's better okay I'll do it yeah
I'll be back I'll go I would be a good
experiment I mean just because I feel
like it was really tasty
bring your brass knuckles and Zack
especially loves everything
one thing doesn't make sense no no go
ahead
can you do that before Friday I really
want to I mean you're like they're like
Arby's Mountain - that was that was an
experience I haven't eaten meat since we
mountain touch my look I'm vegetarian I
am on a feeding window people are
telling me I've been losing weight I
have on lookers and people passing by
saying Ethan you've lost weight so
I can just people on the street people
on the street are saying it so we're
literally word on the street yeah yeah I
don't I'm not skeptical I don't want to
know the truth I think that I just want
to keep going when dev style vegetarian
style ela says she thinks I've lost
weight I have to tell you have some type
fitting pants to feel a little bit
looser when I look at myself in the
mirror I still look fat as ever but
there's a lot of places in my body where
I could lose fat in my face and my arms
and my legs and my thighs my ass I pack
on fat in a lot of places my stomach's
not the only place so it could be
burning out all over the place I don't
want to measure myself because I'm
afraid that I will still be as fast as I
ever was and I'll be totally I'll just
be destroyed and I'm just getting right
and it's all about like you trying you
don't want to speak for you but it
sounds like you're trying to change a
lifestyle which would be something that
would take a while and not not a quick
diet exactly so I'm afraid if I step on
the scale I'll have like gained three
pounds no but let's say oh well I'll be
happy with anything but if it's like the
same I'll just be gutted mm-hmm the last
time I lost a ton of weight I never
stepped on the scale mm-hmm okay
I didn't even measure myself before I
was like I'm too fat let's do something
about this you know I'm tired man let's
just have a better sleep guys don't go
away soon Isis I mean sometimes when I
complain about like that I feel that the
show was boring or something people will
say that they would literally watch us
do anything do we won't put that to the
test
yeah you want to just have me you guys
gonna watch me take a nap no but
shoenice is coming up and you definitely
don't want to miss the shoenice
experience let me show you this Popeyes
freak out subreddit I mean let's sort by
top of all time it's the thing if you
want to compare this to McDonald's dan I
refuse this was like made five days ago
or something because I looked and there
was yeah I think this is well it's a new
phenomenon yeah
okay I mean here's a brawl in the
parking lot some dude touched his truck
and he goes the sound is important here
let's cranked up he hit his truck a big
mistake
maybe mistake he sounds like any powers
remember that show
he's like some pseudo tough guy that
beat up some like old drunk dude well
there you go here's to white people
having a brawl so that's the total Kenny
Powers impersonator so there you have it
two white dudes
it's just getting to this part of it
here's the employees we saw that one
popeyes chicken sandwich fight yeah baby
I think I watched this one it was just
kind of boring we're gonna turn this is
what we just watched okay thank you
google
here's mother god that's Nana got
slammed hard bro this one was awesome I
actually haven't seen the full video
it's all cut up but this is the full one
and the guy in the car is like well this
dis grease stain looks like her [ __ ]
brain fluids well we've got a little bit
of it you guys turned it on well we can
go back and we can go back I think it's
fine Nana got slammed she had it coming
whoa I think she just threw feces at her
she just threw some regards well she
threw the sandwich at her Oh
yeah you guys get the idea it's people
fighting at Popeye's see do you think we
shows too much of Nana getting slammed
so what do we can we go back and just do
a blur or a cut of the Nana getting
slammed part I got blur yeah but unique
circumstance today because of the
shoenice thing so sure
let's cut Danna getting slammed
cut Nana getting slammed even though she
had it coming she did that's what we
call reparations all right oh this is
amazing
Eric Staal were or will star well
ripping hostile
what's his past senator some [ __ ] Prez I
think he's well I'll tell you what his
career is over
that's real y'all think I'm faking it I
got got a second hand footage of someone
reporting it on their TV I have some
updates on this though go ahead well so
don't tell me that it's fake there's no
it's not that it's fake but there's a
couple angles to this one there there is
a poster on Twitter I'll send it on
discord right now who I believe claims
he used to work at the network at NBC
and that the hosts of the segment Chris
Matthews is a notorious office partner
and he thinks it was from the studio hmm
well I'll tell you what Dan the guy
pauses though he kama dated it in his
speech but there's there's some push
back and then and then another twist the
show itself tweeted well they're
claiming that it was a coffee mug that
was scraping across the desk wrong I
mean listen closely how's she
an election no bro you'd have to like
push down with a lot of force to create
that sound I just sent you the tweet
that's he pause did he study and I I
agree so then if you move on here it is
from someone recording a TV screen just
so you know it's real
ela to relieve yet any doubt on this
conspiracy
dude that guy can never be president
right if he wants to run again though
like so what happened in your yeah
Cooper and 2019 that this this CNN
interview so he says this guy Aaron yeah
this is the guy was saying it is
positing that it was in fact Chris
Matthews because he is he I never heard
okay as a guy who has reveled four years
in the fact that Chris Matthews loves
the blasts hot clouds on live TV I'm
here to clear Eric Staal walls name well
they okay there's no T and it's all well
Wow well it's Wow
more like the fart well on live TV
that's what it sounds like
first blah blah blah for Exhibit B oh he
so yes he has receipts
bro this guy actually brought receipts
okay there's Chris Mader
dude it was Chris I totally believe it
what do they have a mic on his [ __ ]
loud dude can't you like you couldn't
you be able to like spread your cheeks
and let it out more silently he's got a
bunch of video I'll hold it in no don't
say that what was that that was Zach
okay was definitely dude you it's so
messed up he's framing all these poor
people I McNally yeah I'm convinced man
told you and and then again I sent you
another tweet which was from his show
hardball it said sorry to disappoint the
conspiracy theorist it was a hashtag
hardball mug scraping across no no way
you just own it you blasted ass give me
about bring me them up I swear to god
someone grab me a mug right now right
ones like I'm gonna tell you there's no
way to produce that sound unless you
like with a lot of force pushing down
there's water in it if you just glide it
yeah but you know first of all push it
really hard but yeah how do you produce
that sound I mean unless ly it's like
rubber on the bottom why would there be
rubber on the bottom interesting well I
just did a whole 180 on Eric so it can
be president poor Eric a half life is
back after a decade of silence half life
has announced actually the announcement
comes on Thursday they're going to give
all the details but half life is back
it's coming out for V
are in early 2020 and I never thought I
was gonna die I'm setting up a VR room
mm-hmm
apparently they're valve is created this
crazy VR technology where your fingers
track in the game and you're grabbing
[ __ ] it's like so realistic this is the
first flagship the are game I've played
all the valve games in the current VR
headset for what's the name of the
steams current VR headset oh they just
released it right no yeah the one we
have at home just made for us why am i
blind can and something maybe the vibe
the vibe yeah the vibe is amazing I
played all of the are valves games on
vibe and they're like mind-blowing
amazing and I was like these guys are
working on something crazy I know it I
think I even said on the show I think
half-life 3 is gonna be the VR game it's
not half-life 3 it did say that at some
point I think I said it go back into the
law that way although it's not 3 it's
half-life Alex which is another
character in the half-life series so
it's a new series well I think what it
is is it's basically a prequel to
half-life 2 which takes place before the
events of half-life 2 took place but um
oh do it that's gonna be so sick you can
track your fingers bro yeah I've uh I'm
not that in a home thing but you know
there's I have done that vr stuff where
it tracks your fingers that that you
know what it's it's called like the void
or something mmm it's like it's that
like a mall or something it's like a
thing you go to and so it's a whole new
it's new [ __ ]
it's a neurology no wonder you would
have to buy like the five is not I think
it's not vibe you've got it's a big
investment super expensive I read it
could cost a thousand dollars just for
the VR pieces and then I think it
probably plugs into the computer on top
of it it's a very expensive the whole
thing is so expensive because you gotta
have a good computer need gaming
companies
empty wrong you do that exactly you have
to be you have to basically be rich like
you to play that exactly it's it's
pretty outrageous but somehow I'm sure
that everyone's gonna buy huh
cuz its halflife you can't not buy it um
I'm hoping that they they accounted for
that and you like even though it's
designed for that you'll hopefully be
able to play it without VR - yeah well
here's what I think the future of VR
like they have - no I don't think that
you shouldn't need to stand up and walk
around that's just outrageous and it's
so limiting what I think VR needs to be
you know what I think they might be
doing is that you can just sit in your
seat with the VR set you use your hands
to control the game you can turn right
because it's for wireless you can turn
it like that in your chair but forcing
someone first of all to have a battle
every room there's no sitting and things
well I don't think it's optimized for
that most games are optimized for
standing and walking around and I think
the whole standing walking round thing
is kind of a gimmick anyway if I'm being
honest because you don't yeah and you
don't you don't need that to be immersed
so what I think is gonna happen is that
this game's gonna be played sitting down
and then you don't in the whole room you
don't need a whole room you probably
hold something in your hand that's a
controller you know that control is like
directional and [ __ ] like that
I've only tried something about at
Justin's I mean all the VR I try to
divide or something that it's just a you
you see you don't need to oh the
PlayStation VR yeah yeah so I think I'll
be like that okay
half-life 3 baby let's go I'm getting
worried about that because I like
watching you play you can watch you set
up a second screen which means you have
to be even richer but then I don't get
to watch it in VR you can get we could
probably get you VR glasses
that's like the docs will get the dogs
VR theater so we can watch I agree I
don't that's why I've always thought VR
is kind of a gimmick I just don't see it
mm-hm
but I'm gonna buy this I'm gonna give it
a shot they can't do it nobody
so let's see what's up Jake Paul cries
after Logan Paul loses a meme album a
meme album but we're at 30 minutes so
I'll save these for Friday with that
being said we're gonna throw it to a
quick commercial break when we come back
soon world will never be the same
because shoenice is joining us via Skype
he has a phobia of flying so he was
unable to make it out of here he's also
I guess you know and he did say that if
he's gonna take a train here it's on
one-way ticket for him so that was a lot
of responsibility for us too
what is that what did that was a mean
that he's gonna bump up with us that
he's not going back I don't know what
that means yeah let's move let's take
the relationship one thing at a time
let's not discuss one-way tickets just
get with that being said guys shoenice
on skype the world will never be the
same either way either way after this
commercial break so stick around we will
see you in a short moment thank you guys
quip is the gift you need to give
yourself this holiday season because you
only get one first impression and you
better make sure your teeth look
beautiful and that your breath is fresh
and golden as it gets
that's where quip comes in quip calm /h
through you're gonna get this beautiful
electric toothbrush it's got perfect
soft bristles so that you can do the two
minutes you're supposed to it vibrates
when you click the button at pulsates
every 30 seconds to make sure that each
quadrant of your mouth is getting that
perfect dentist recommended pressure
that your breath is clean and when that
mistletoes overhead you're not ready to
Peck you're ready to French write ela
mm-hmm it doesn't even matter if it's
your aunt or even your mom I should
matter it should matter listen they've
got they've now got philosophers that
come with pre marks string to help you
get just enough floss they deliver fresh
brush heads floss and toothpaste to your
door every three months with free
shipping so your routine is always the
right one showing over 3 million healthy
mouths and get clipped today starting at
just $25 if you go to get clipped com /h
through right now you'll get your first
refill pack for free that's your first
refill pack for free at get quick calm
/h 3 spelled g ET q UI p.com /h Lurie
quit the good habits company
door - baby they're gonna bring food to
you anywhere from anywhere whatever you
want at any time its door - you got a
long day at work you lazy at home do
your parents not pack you lunch anymore
you still haven't gotten over that
million if to prepare meals for yourself
are you crushing it at work laser focus
and you don't want to bring yourself
away these are all legitimate reasons to
order yourself door - or hey how about
the reason that I always order from door
- I'm just too lazy and I don't feel
like cooking how about that I mean
that's why people order food right let's
let's forget about let's not lie to
ourselves door - connects you to your
favorite restaurants in your city
ordering is easy open the door - app
choose whatever you want to eat and your
food will be delivered to you wherever
you are not only is your favorite
restaurant pizza joint already on door -
but there are over 340,000 restaurants
and 3300 cities so you might even find a
new one you like - with door-to-door
delivery in over 50 States and Canada
order from your local go to Zoar choose
from your favorite national restaurants
like Chipotle Wendy's chick-fil-a the
Cheesecake Factory
mmm don't worry about that let's let
dinner come to you with door - check
this out right now our listeners get
five dollars for free off their first
order of $15 or more when you download
the door - app and enter promo page
promo code h3 let me repeat that because
it was that too good to be true
no $5 for free after your first order of
over $15 when you download the door -
app and enter promo code h3 don't forget
that's promo code HD for a free five
dollars off your first order from door -
lets get that food moving son that's
their slogan that I just made up that's
not really the slogan door - lets get
that food moving boy
and now the moment you've all waited for
the great shoe nice shoe for short we
like to call a mr. su as a sign of
respect and irreverence the great early
youtuber YouTube legend YouTube legend
the man the fact that he's even alive is
a miracle he's eaten everything from
deodorant to tampons and everything in
between
glue glass you name it he's eating it
the only thing he hasn't eaten is me
incidentally which I am afraid of but
let's get to the bottom of that now
introducing the incredible everlasting
the unkillable
shoenice welcome to the show show so
shoot tell me this you know I've been
trying to get you in here for a while
you says that you cannot fly so we've
got you here via Skype what's the deal
with the flying well basically just come
are you good go ahead okay no work right
the tape is great too by the way
nice touch wait a minute I can't you fly
it's just
alright I crashed in a helicopter desert
storm we flew home over the ocean coming
home and we trapped like 300 feet
whatever that is and all everybody's
partying with the flight attendants 10
minutes later two flight attendants were
late and I was just like I just can't
flag but a train takes me to California
but I don't take a return so when I
think what you're saying is that you
have some kind of trauma with with
flying yeah I took four xanax I was
banned from Southwest for a week going
to Vegas the ladies like this guy's free
cuz she handed me a vodka and
I said oh man you forgot the vodka he
went up to the captain and said he's a
threat and they're like no he is an axe
so I fall asleep I get up to go to the
bathroom and that captain comes on the
thing goes see two three one please stay
seated till we receive you with the
authorities
so we land in Vegas in the cops are like
okay where is he the captain's like this
guy when all the people coming off the
planer like it wasn't him it was her
they just started screaming all this
[ __ ] at her and everything see how I can
swing my head with the gorilla tape yeah
that's fantastic you really saw a
gorilla or some what they have but so
what what did they accuse you of on the
airplane because that's a fascinating
story that got that you got yatta too
quickly over right right we got plenty
of time on the podcast so anyways tosh
point-o just hurried me oh my god they
showed me a big will and I had to say it
used to be a kid on it you're way better
than tosh.o they gave me they gave me
300 subscribers the next day
I'm opening three thousand oh three
million maybe three million but I want
to know what happened alright but anyway
so I get off the plane and the caps are
there yeah and everybody's like in the
Casa captain he's like you want him to
be permanent what do you call when
you're just like no flight yeah flight
risk
no flight you're basically you're
basically in the same category as Isis
in the lady she's always a [ __ ] so I
walked out of this Las Vegas Airport
with the Nevada cops watching me eat a
roll of toilet paper on YouTube and
that's where I started just getting
really popular but why did they accuse
me of doing on the plane dude what did
what did what did that what did they
think you did on the airplane to call
the police oh I I was annoying a lady
but I was telling jokes I was doing Stan
I just heard he was doing his alcohol
stunts that big
were you slamming bought bottles okay so
so okay yeah I believe you you're
apologizing if I if I'm correct for
calling her an Israeli [ __ ] say yeah I
didn't even know red field was she
posted that on my Twitter she said you
better eat more toilet paper shoenice
with all that [ __ ] coming out of your
eyes right and then you said oh my I
said finally some subscribers is that
why you do what you do so nice because
you guys thank you is that what we did
to by the way we were watching your
videos like a long time ago well who
hasn't I mean she nice dude hanging out
with even saying I can't but you fed so
many McDouble 'z I had so many emails
like we gave 30 McDowell's out to people
so that's your fourth most viewed video
okay your main channel yeah I'm proud of
it you called me the moral center of
youth
this guy I remember you just saying it's
a nothing babe nation we got a show of a
nation down but I'm gonna say will be a
whole nother entity you're saying about
tonight yes yes no I don't wanna we're
getting late the next jackass - the ass
bro this the jack oh you want to get
drunk so sure you viewer well you you
said that you're just happy about the
subscribers so is that what you do what
you do because state you guys black me
on an email but I was driving out to
meet you in Joey's world tour yes a fat
dude with a tuna sub in his chin and I'm
just like all right Ethan just blocked
me on email I can understand that I set
him forty of them made 5 videos saying
screw you guys and an Joey's world tour
said his cousin died and say
Diego and I'm like wait you hold on the
whole thing happened in three hours you
know you want it so at least you didn't
say that
let's discuss this support you've held a
grudge against us for a while because
bye-bye
well hold on you've been upset let's say
yet not a grudge let's tone it down you
think we [ __ ] how many voices do you
have going rattling around in your head
I just wanted to eat three off the
toilet paper but that's a good thing
because I don't wait my ass bro my bad
oh my yeah we just started well you go
so fast you're like that's true I just I
just let you do you you can just say hey
go ahead you nice and talk for ten
minutes and you cut in on any kind of
the story I'll lead you off to boogie
being a scrub keemstar punching logan
paul in the face cuz i ain't no ksi okay
let's get to that but the well we'll get
to each one of those things my dad put
up put a pin in it but you so let's get
to this beef you say that that we blew
you off you wanted to come down to LA to
do a collab now the way that I remember
it is that you emailed us and you said
hey I'm gonna be in LA right so I know
yeah so so first of all your account is
that you came down to LA to meet us and
then we blew you off but you four
emailed us and said I'm gonna be in LA
and I said that sounds interesting
oh that's right so it looked like I was
saying you already invited me and I'm
just gonna here to hang out yeah
but Joey's world tour was gonna have me
in San Diego but he said his cousin died
so I you I definitely will take that as
the okay okay good so okay that was easy
we cleared that right up you know now
tell me about Tom you said something
about Boogie being a scrubs
nobody's the best no bogey is cool guy
but what happened was I joined king of
the web and that's where I
got a lot of haters I don't know if you
knew this but king of the web they just
pay you cash for getting the most votes
so this fan came in and said this dudes
picking on me why don't you join King
the web I come in I see you know some
gangster from South Central running up
against jenna Marbles new boyfriend I
said I'll try it and my Wolfpack just
came in and you can buy it and we just
fed in and said and we took so much
money on us you know Markinson ball is
going you can ask anybody about the real
shoenice troopers know about king of the
web where you could get paid big money
you would have been rich and no no let
me ask you I'll see you said something
about punching keemstar in the face not
never
yeah I'm telling you this dude sat there
and said Oh FML shoenice rapes kids he
found it off of a dude's YouTube channel
that serving time in prison for child
distribution the irony
so I told keemstar you go ahead and you
make a video about me raping kids but
here's the family's numbers here's the
police reports he blocked me on Twitter
and never made that video
hey keemstar will you'd like this you
better make something about me tomorrow
I'm on a date okay
now tell me are you are you at this very
moment a sober shoenice given Halloween
trick or treaters you know better I
think I got one left here what we did is
we just helped out the homeless on
Thanksgiving they don't what is that
before you drink it show that to us it
says pimp ermine pepper man and I need
proof
wow that's serious like most people on
YouTube they fake it well that's not
liquor since 8th grade bus stop bro
eighth grade bus stop but I wanted to
say a quick cheers I don't care what
anybody says about me Ethan and ela I
just though you guys are a cool couple
relax and I don't look at your faces I
just listen to you and a lot of people
just listen to you you're good
voice just like mink huh just like now
here here's mine Simpson having sex with
the Terminator does fine for Jimmy
you're licking turn me you're not Sarah
Connor get to the choppa now shoo why is
it how does he get in to go ahead and to
end how was it they you said you started
drinking when you're in eighth grade how
does that come to be what kind of
childhood leads to eighth grade slamming
about called thank you thank you thank
you I came out of my mom's vagina in
1969 May 30th the doctor looked at me in
the half-eaten umbilical cord and said
we got a special one here I was born
underneath my older brother Jeff he was
the most corrupt one out of the three
Shoei brothers we didn't mean no harm
but we were just some crazy mofos we
were born to a young Irish lass my mom
good people my dad met her he was an 18
year old German she was a 15 year old
Irish woman who knows what happens
either way we all came out we all
started growing up I asked for a baby in
a carriage and my brother put gasoline
on and sent it down a hill in the
neighbor's yard he had just turned five
I was four and my brother was two we
took sharpies and drew them all over
aluminum house we didn't mean to we just
were crazy so nice sorry have you ever
told the story to a therapist yeah and
they said sorry son there's nothing we
can do here so shoot I want to know yeah
I mean the store was a bit of a
nonlinear story of your childhood we'll
bounce through it we'll get better once
I start eating glue in elementary school
and I go to the special room that'll be
good so when did you have your first
drink of alcohol hey let's take off our
hands together right now Ethan okay
teacher two one whoa that's the dome
right there might be a traitor DEA over
gurgi your honor
now shoo tell me when was the first time
you you had alcohol at what age um we
always had the pictures of our dad
letting us drink bottles of beer of
three four years old every picture you
see what album oh my god every picture
in our photo albums the old ones where
people had to put pictures in an album
to enjoy memories we will never hear
that again unless you're on Pawn Stars
and that's all fake
you guys are real so anyways yeah every
four three two four eight years old was
your father an alcoholic
Ethan an ill and my parents drank so
much beer when we were kids we had to
use their old koozies for arm floaties
at the public pool bottoms out you laugh
they keep a grown man afloat I don't
have lice the beach on one arm gone
fishing on the other when I get to LA
bro this is just a little spot but I'm
gonna shoot now shoot do you know you
can appreciate that but I got a little
beyond this arm you know little bit of
course the bass God knows now shoot tell
me this when you talk about you when you
talk about your childhood and the
floaties in the public pool do you look
back on your childhood fondly or are you
glad that you're now in a dirt when I
look back at my childhood my father led
his life by his dick my mom was a drunk
in a Chevy van she'd go on cruises and
we were left home alone on a farm we
were kicked out of so many apartment
buildings for shutting the power down
when women were on oxygen tanks we're on
the front paper for second forest fire
in a mountain but I'm telling you right
now driving what was the question
do you look back on your childhood
fondly are you glad to be always happy
cuz me and my brothers were just not my
older brother he was the like you gotyou
this now that's how you're gonna be a
five year old so just when do you see
yourself as like a normal human being or
do you see yourself as someone that's
just a little elevated in terms of the
way that their mind works it's not
exactly easy to have a
a one-on-one conversation with you are
you aware of that fact are you just
drunk or is there something else I'm
sober bro it's excited but they ever
hear of acting Ethan
you ever hear she is that what you're
doing right now D are you acting right
now is that what you're saying I'm John
Cena so let's turn off that so let's
turn off the acting and have a real
commerce yeah here we go here we go
three two one go hey everyone - nice
again so how did you end up at what
point at what point did you move out
onto your own and separate from your
parents I was gonna get to that but you
scared you always interrupt people I was
gonna get to that in like two seconds
all right so anyways me my brothers were
crazy my father was led by his dick he
divorced my mom and eventually my mom
was so crazy the social services said
come get your kids or we're gonna put
true we're gonna put them in a coma and
my father's a cool guy you know he likes
[ __ ] but so we went with my father so
in fifth grade I started eating Elmer's
glue I was just a champ
remember Elmer's pain why did you start
having glue what was the motivation just
wish I had some I just loved glue just I
love the adhesive off of like Monopoly
games man you know the show freaky
eaters yeah that's all fake they
wouldn't take me cuz I'm a real but do
you see yourself as a freaky eater and
though and that was no no no I just love
that [ __ ] I always did it for money to
it I'm not a what does it call tyka paid
in cash always okay so we started eating
glue is that when your mental state
started to deteriorate
[Laughter]
I'm sorry
who else is that yeah I say I heard Mars
I heard Schwarzenegger Rocky's taking
this [ __ ] so you were talking about you
started eating Elmer's glue and then
that evolved until I was always a
performer Ethan and I was born with a
beautiful smile for a crest commercial
no I'm not John Cena and I was just the
funniest guy in the world
and people used to laugh I was voted
class clown in two different high
schools one I never even finished all
right we'll get that we'll get to there
and so so at what point did you move out
on your own um 17 will go right to that
if you want
so anyways my father sends me to rehab
because I'm drinking beer oh my god
boohoo we used to do a beer ball the
people hated me coming to lunch beer
ball parties or any BYOB I'd walk in
with a 12-pack they'd be like oh no you
gotta go
my buddy brought down why is a KERS
because you drink too much I know I have
the I took everything when people took
one hit of acid I needed three when
people took to cast so they're like this
guy's can't drink all of our beers that
way they don't know that was my friends
though they just said you ain't getting
any of ours right now you're gonna kick
me out of a party yeah but I just was
like yeah man
so I just started slamming booze and all
right let's get kicked out of the house
so my dad's like you listen I just spent
$25,000 on your rehab I said well guess
what Dad I never even knew about acid
mushrooms or heroin so thanks a lot
because I spent 25 grand on that I said
you didn't spend [ __ ] hey that your
insurance paid it so I said dad I got to
move out he was you better so I moved on
I moved in with my brother my brother
Jeff he was a roofer so was his
roommates I became a roofer and we all
just I want a trip so I started taking
acid and mushrooms and just being in a
freakin nature but the summer ended
I wanted to go back to high school so I
moved back in with my mom we're the only
two white people for 18 blocks we didn't
care we're not prejudiced I'm in a high
school where the principal's getting his
ear half-court off I said mom I gotta
quit
it's just crazy I was playing basketball
with the varsity team and they threw a
ball at me I thought they were throwing
at the other guy and they smashed my
nose and blood went everywhere they just
laughing so hard you just I had to go so
I joined the army hmm here we go here we
go
why why why do you suppose there was so
much alcohol and drug use is there some
kind of secret pain that unites is
trying to know my father never suck his
dick in my ass in my stepmother was a
[ __ ] but you can watch your father pound
you're set Mon there because that's not
your mom you know you do likely never
watched my mom oh the whole neighbor's
kids we'd all climb up on the roof I'd
say
cigarettes on the movie Goodfellas you
would charge the neighborhood kids to
watch your dad bang your stepmom
stepmother she was rushing good people
good people how much money did you make
in that racket I don't know I was in
eighth grade right and uh and did you
ever beat off watching that never know
okay it's one thing sound tickets to the
neighbors kids oh damn it's your dad's
dick bro I did that and did the kids
ever be it off they were on the roof
like how did that ever suspecting you
were selling tickets to watch him have
sex I told them when he told my mom that
he [ __ ] this neighbor went before she
died so yeah I had to get back at him
and what what was his reaction to that
mom he never he's just an [ __ ]
millionaire like his brothers I don't
talk to any of the shoe ease I don't
talk to my son
the mother that came out of him
the opposite yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that'd be weird
but either way men Ethan can we continue
on well here on no let's not move along
because I'm fascinated by what's what's
happened before the army what's droving
you to that point I mean yeah a lot you
just said a lot for example that you
don't talk to your son why don't I was
born a raging drunk I'll tell you
something right now my mom was a raging
drunk and so was I and you take this AAA
meetings that was made up for DWI people
I gotta take 680 meetings before I go
back to the court I'm telling you right
now dude to 12 steps I found a bottle of
Ikon the 13 step and shared it with my
mom she used to have a gallon of vodka
underneath the kitchen sink you know you
couldn't even pour water back in and
fake it she says if you want to drink
don't you pour water back in so you said
mark it with a sharpie mark it with a
sharpie so she you learn what did you
benefits
Noren drained of all day it seems like
you used to see your mom drunk a lot
growing up you know what what did you
think about that when you would see your
mom didn't I tell you about AAA meetings
I ain't speaking at an a a meeting I'm a
raging drunk bro no I know I made up for
Rosie I see you don't you don't want to
go you don't want to go get a motor
we're I know I used to take my mom's
vodka
it wasn't emotional I thought a blackout
in understand we don't want to go there
so that's fine so don't tell me go deep
what fingers yeah of course well what
did what did you used to think when you
saw your mom walking around the house
drunk didn't care that was normal
she used to go on vacations yeah what
does that mean did you ever find out
what that she used to come home and sing
songs she's to come home with a drunk
boyfriend and he thought he could take
advantage of her and I mean my brothers
would bounce you ever seen a drunk guy
from a bar get beat up by a six seven
and nine year old I believe it
we're all bad [ __ ] that's why
I'm going in the UFC these hands weren't
made for knitting sweaters
I mean why I come from a hundred years
of boxing bro butter years of rock so
why haven't you spoken to your own son
and so long this is easy to hit my son
is 20 now but he's just a loser like his
mom they're just this idiotic country
folk that don't understand I spoiled
them too much I had a stepdaughter she
had a girl from another dude I'll punch
you in the face I ever see you [ __ ]
never a thank you but either way I
didn't even give a [ __ ] I just spoiled
them just get him everything get ready I
got a lawsuit I felt through a skylight
broke my back I like a half a million
blew it on video games and PlayStation
safer and our dogs cuz they wanted them
either way you got a move on anything
you only have one chance at life and my
whole Shoei family I'm changing my name
there's shoenice cuz literally my family
is nothing but a bunch of [ __ ]
one-way [ __ ] men and it says my
grandmother died and my grandfather died
I was raised Russian Orthodox thank God
because look at the Catholic Church but
either way I had a grandfather from
Russia that loved us more than any
[ __ ] schooi ever did the next
question and and and day sorry I think
my sheets are here yes she yeah Mays
knocking on the door and so I love
hotels no bills when you hate the
neighbors they leave in a few days so
how are you car you uh currently you
nice do you think that you would make a
good Joker jennamarbles leave sorry
she's yeah do you think you would make a
good Joker man here we go Jensen having
sex with the joke
Oh take that's fine for Gemma near
Lincoln right right sure that was a Jack
Nicholson fellas you know that Heath
Ledger got murdered by the Olsen twins
and they covered it up with a billion
dollars but then the final okay so so
shoo tell me this you are a knock on the
door is that just him because there was
no dog barking hey puppy so you told him
you're on a job interview shoo and I
don't believe that that was being
truthful interview everything I say the
mystery is the history the history is
the mystery so what what okay you're out
you're in a hotel why are you in a hotel
currently because I can't stand humanity
and come what does that have to do with
being in a hotel people like you
well what does that have to do with
staying in a hotel I'm sorry
what is miss right now I knew this TB
was common but we're just a little late
but I told them to go down the hall but
they only got one more TV to deliver I
wouldn't get a new TV today at your
hotel room yeah we think I own a house
Ethan but that's you know what we settle
this dude down right now just kidding so
how do you how do you pay a hotel bill
do you have money
I'm a YouTube entertainer I get a
paycheck every morning from cameo that's
no no that's right an Armani let me pay
good you guys be rich do a cameo for us
right now yeah no problem yeah can you
get her it's my birthday it's my
birthday my name is Ethan is my
birthday's coming up I'm gonna turn 32
all right here we go
oh yeah hey have you say your names
quick hey Ella
shoenice again well basically your
beautiful husband Ethan just paid for a
cameo
I charge 15 ellaby's charges 40 so your
cameo is beefing on other cameo stars
this is your wife Ethan shoot if I
didn't know better you're trying to
seduce my wife you can have a wonderful
day I wish I could see you right now
viola I know you look pretty
thank y'all shoes so let's go to them
let's go to the let's go to the army you
sign up for the army how long did you
serve and what division all right here
we go bro I joined the army because I
was in that gangster high school and the
principal got his ear cut off so I told
my mom I'm just gonna Quinn go to army
it was the last year that you could get
in where you promised the army you got
your GED at your AIT station after that
you couldn't get in without a high
school diploma I say well what do you
got he's like I got plumbing and
electricity
that's so huh I don't want to get
shocked so I took Parman so I went to
basic training I was the class clown
always the class clown and I shaved a
question mark in my head now you have
your head shape but you don't have it
fully shaved and now
homeboys were putting lines back in the
Michael Jackson late eighties days and I
said give me some of that goop and I put
a big question mark in my head with a
dot right here and then I were in chow
hall and I already lost my ID so they
were yelling at me and this one drill
sergeant seeing me in the barracks
looking for this ID because everything
just spread out all over the place you
got people that just hate society
screaming at you and I was just like a
man and this guy's like that you got you
realize what's gonna happen in chow hall
I so uh and so we go to chow hall you
got to take your cap off I'm in line
trying to stand as tall as I can and I'm
looking at the peripheral of my
sergeants like what he comes over he
grassy he goes you got a question on
your mind private now I did this in
reception center two weeks are just
being processed and the army to make
sure you're not some fool and I guess I
got through and I that that thing was he
was like okay man you I got it you got a
question on your mind private I got the
answer and they brought me outside and
they had a tray of food down on the
ground so I was like all right they
gotta let me eat so I went down I pulled
up this whatever mystery meat and it
sucked it all down I went through as a
New Yorker with a question mark on my
head where 90% of the US Army is
southern people that think they're gonna
still rise again hey rise this southern
states so anyways I just leave I go to
the AIT and I'm the number one plumber
ever so I'm like the top plumber dog in
the Army Reserves as a whatever so I go
home and I'm like hey I'm moving to
Florida so find me a barracks down there
for my one weekend a month you must
notice and they're like now we don't
have anything in Florida we're gonna put
you on IRR I said okay so the Baghdad
starts getting blown up in 1990-91 I
just fought 20 police officers and one
so I said yeah I'm ready for war so I go
off to war man and they got
this whole process where rom irr with a
bunch of other bad news bears from the
army and every guys is like yo man we
don't need no plumber and we don't need
you want to be a tribe and then this one
sirens uh-uh-uh huh
that [ __ ] gonna burn the Sheep I
said why and he said [ __ ] but I thought
he said sheep and I said why there's
sheep out in the desert so I was a [ __ ]
burner so I just stirred everybody [ __ ]
and I loved it
diesel fuel human feces and everybody
just said hey crazy it was like a scene
from platoon I'm just way better looker
is that what plumbers do out there you
just you burn does burn [ __ ] yeah
sometimes the master sergeant major
would come out and yet I go hey go ahead
cuz I be burning the [ __ ] but then I had
to clean his [ __ ] cuz I didn't put the
tin back I can't put it in back while
the shit's burnin he gets a spurt and so
that's that some would say that you saw
combat out there just by stirring okay
well basically I was in the SNT troop so
we were like two miles behind we just
went into [ __ ] northern Kuwait and we
seen a lot of crazy [ __ ] but it just
like he could it all happened within
three days and then we're just POWs blah
blah blah I was standing on the back of
a five-ton without money Cavalier or
whatever they call it helmet and my
sergeant always said wear it so I got
blown off cuz we were taking these
pallets over the dune instead of driving
him in and [ __ ] Huey's windows blew
me off so I wake up in a mash tent with
my eye out to here and they're like you
want a Purple Heart and I'm like I ain't
going home ain't going back to roof and
I want this [ __ ] to last as long as
Vietnam
she's like the war's been over so I went
back to my tent my sergeants like you
when you gonna go home he actually
sounded like the [ __ ] dude from that
movie me myself and Irene so you wanted
to stay you wanted to continue serving
two of what going on
yeah I just I decided I just loved
shit-stirring with your calling in yeah
I just love protecting people what can
you go back to the purple did you get a
Purple Heart
no I'll be fine swelling down and
eventually so what happened I didn't
quite understand what was the injury you
took I got blown off the back of a
five-ton acting like an idiot what what
blew you off the down pressure of the
helicopter what we were doing saving
time so we're oaken pallets of like Mr
reason whatever it was mostly just
seeing the POWs but we would just send
him over because we had all this [ __ ]
barricade you know the Bob wired she had
to move at all times so we just get one
Huey's going and I don't know bro my
sergeant said never talk about what
happened again you just found the truck
yeah I was actually they give you a
Purple Heart for falling off a truck no
I didn't get a Purple Heart man okay
night it they say go home they say go
home I say I ain't going what do you
think Ethan you think I'm lying to my
dd-214 bro I don't think you're lying
I'm just fascinated by I think it's
interesting with no but you know what
the best head injury was when I felt
through a skylight in the Union man tell
me about - yeah I was just like I got
back to this Union I was like hey man
I'm just gonna be a union guy I'm done
with all the roof and owning I had a
company called nice roofing you got a
leak we'll take a peek and we're not
going to colleges cuz I'm the back of my
truck people loved it it said but now
that was said the guy yeah I was the guy
that would just go to your roof and I'd
be like okay again charge these people
for current and then a little old lady
would come out and say all right
[ __ ] repair for eighteen hundred and
I like I just went broke being too nice
so I should have been named bad roofing
but anyway so I'm in the Union and this
dudes like hey go over and grab this
[ __ ] this is where I'm in the opiate
class-action lawsuit I'm getting about a
half
million we'll get to that so I'm just
[ __ ] and zoots like I said it's rainin
bro he goes just pull out the Li cords
in case the foreman shows up so I walk
by the skylight but it's painted metal
and I thought it was metal pans and he
do it on a flat big huge roof picture a
football field that just you know
nothing you've ever been on and then I
was just like I leaned into the glass
and I broke through and I just went
headfirst and I got this [ __ ]
right here does this from my uncle throw
me into the fireplace rank average per
million what do you think you took brain
damage from that doesn't take a rocket
surgeon Ethan I'm looking up at my
Foreman he's like oh my god I'm like how
are you in heaven I fell first Andrew
just like so I ended up going to the
hospital for like two weeks seven
vertebrae fractured learn how to walk
again to that change did that change
kind of how your brain worked after that
did you feel you were Davi on the
oxycontin did we're gonna get to that
the oxycontin and so you think what are
you drinking alcohol on oxycontin till
you can't even just like I do that
sometimes see with my head but anyways
I'm just hanging out right and I'm
finally getting out of the hospital but
I'm feeling good and they're just like
yeah they're just like we're gonna give
you a siik on hydrocodone oxycodone
morphine I mean literally I was fed with
all these [ __ ] opiates and I was
never hope to opiates so I get home and
I'm mom enjoying life I'm just sitting
there watching you know my son played
GTA to use about three he looked up to
me and said dad what's a hooker and so
I'm just [ __ ] my lawyer comes in so
I'll get you a million dollars he got me
a half a million but I was jumped out on
the opiates for years man finally I just
was hiding in cornfields in my
neighborhood my wife was just like
you're psycho and I just like you know
people always say I left my I didn't
leave anything man I was society bro
and I was just like I was just like so
jumped out on these opiates and I was
just like I gotta quit everything right
now and I just threw it all in the
[ __ ] swamp and she said you still
gotta go and the state troopers came up
I said listen I own this property I
bought it with my lawsuit this is a
[ __ ] dirty ass [ __ ] that's gonna own
this place someday but I'm out of here
I'm taking the Subaru and I jumped into
the Chevy Blazer just the fooler and
headed on down the road bro and this is
right when YouTube was blowing up I had
[ __ ] Tosh point not tosh point-o
world's dumbest
I had Vice coming at me I had so many
things going on and I was just jumped
out I met this chick and I was just
eating all their kallana fins and I was
just like wow so your whole career was
picking up right when you were living
your family it was all happening if you
watch the first videos on the main
channel which is going be you can find
them there's twenty five thousand
YouTube videos with my name in them
that's a lot of video that's a lot of
that [ __ ] more than you more than you
h3h3 oh yeah and and pooty pooty pi
million subscribers it's about sub do
you ratio bro it's about sub view ratio
and I'm gonna take over this little h3
h3 podcast you have and we're going back
out on the streets once Theodore gets a
nursery school because you'll have time
off bro you have time off you have to
get back out in the street when you just
dude there with the dirty jogging shorts
or jogging pants going vague nation yeah
people want that that's true I know
every one of your comments you don't I
follow every one of your comments
what's let's retire YouTube is gone
sure let me ask you this when you left
your house well your wife kicked you out
of the house for him understanding
correctly was that the first last time
you saw your son yeah yeah sad scene now
we talked on Instagram whatever one shot
he's just like me bro he's just like my
father and that my grandfather when I
was a kid my father [ __ ] left
my mom for another dick and my
grandfather hated my father for that and
then just my father I [ __ ] you at 17 I
moved out you can kiss my ass dad I'm
moving out and then my son at 12 years
old
I'm jumped out on opiates but I got
clean and I tried plenty of times to
just say hey but it's the Shoei factor
there's something in our genes and I'm
so happy I got 100% of my mom I got 100
my brothers got a little bit of it
because they are we just said the
homeless packing baby you know to get us
a bottle liquor but how you take them
out all right
are you ever concerned that you may be
your son sir oh [ __ ] dude you live one
time on this planet dude you can't let
the opinions of people in your room
today affect your tomorrow because they
won't be in it Daniel tell you that do
you do ever think maybe well maybe oh
I've never seen one
shoenice let's see it were you saving
that was that a fit you're waiting for
the right time is that a meal for you
well come on your duty tampons and you
can't finish giant Reese's Pieces here
we go oh my god yeah that's what's up
that's a pro I like how you pause for em
to think about what's happening for a
more no break yet don't believe by the
way well you are natural born
entertainer shoe yeah I want to ask you
how is it possible that you don't blink
think about that while you chill hard
you know I love how he pauses
[Laughter]
yeah you need some liquid was that
alcohol or water so through the audio
listeners he's got a half pound Reese's
Cup the biggest I've ever seen it's
pretty much the size of his head he's
stuffing in his mouth it's incredibly
thick and dense at the top and he's
really going out of man that's
impressive you put some alcohol in his
mouth lamb every inch of his mouth is
Reese's it out oh yeah the way he may
die right here on string it's no red
he's starting to look more like Joey
World Tour put it back in it looks so
much like feces I'm so honored to be
getting a real skew nice right here bro
you look like a warrior right now
are you are you okay yeah okay yeah yeah
so do you need a wipe up or something
are you good yeah do you know how much
calories isn't that thing that was so
that was so impressive yeah yeah wipe up
please I mean I think I just March grab
these we just witness history
thoughts he actually had to blink at the
end
did he blink and you were watching it
was staring up hmm what do you thin
terview going it's an interview I don't
know it's a performance yes I like up
one-man show yeah and I crying back I
mean it looked like he was eating [ __ ]
feces I don't think I can ever eat
Reese's again I already could fourth oh
no I'm no I'm justified what if he I
think he may be dead all I see it was
walls yeah I mean he turn so red at one
point well right now we're just looking
at a picture of his wall he's cleaning
up I think but oh I mean I hope he's not
just dead on the kitchen are on the
bathroom floor of his Motel 6
Brad good as new
I told these mofos about three times I'm
doing these in a tree tree but they're
Mexicans
I gotta get this TV moved in hold on
okay go ahead
they said though there's a TV
installation apparently do you get TVs
installed at hotel rooms now oh my god
someone come help me it's water all over
the wall
ma'am so I never lived in a hotel I
don't know I mean I've heard of it
before but like at a motel 6 and I know
a think you're better off just paying
rent for a place I mean that's that's
like when do you pay all I could
possibly guess who could possibly guess
what's really going on over there thank
you
yeah let's see him let's put him on the
mic in here put him on the mic can they
hear us can you hear us can't hear us at
the chorus bro we got to turn off the
power and stuff okay glad you got the
can you hear me oh that's it we were
blessed to have that it was a it was a
lot of I mean a lot happened a lot we
learned a lot you know I think but there
was a lot he's an interesting guy I
think if I can recap we learned a lot of
stuff about you one it sounds like a
very very rough childhood yeah it's hard
to tell what's really going on and he
obviously doesn't like to really talk
about it and I think there's how how
does shoenice become shoenice I feel
like it's hard to tell but it's also not
like well yeah it's obvious that it
wasn't a typical healthy up granite
gneiss is like a diamond only under
extreme pressure and environment can you
produce such a brilliant jewel but is is
um you know how sometimes you would make
the
where he's all upset at us and we will
be kind of worried right but I feel like
I'm not worried anymore he's kind of uh
can you call Dan I'm just looking at the
discord yeah it's on the screen hold on
he stepped away from the mic okay yeah
well just don't show that
yeah go ahead sorry I I don't feel like
as worried as we were and you feel less
worried after that and is like I don't
feel like he's someone who would hurt no
I don't worry Oh another person is just
a crazy entertainer I was never really
concerned about him coming to our house
or anything but I don't know I mean it'd
be hard to sit in the same room as him
and control that you would have no
control
there's no no good yeah but I think he
was he was drunk for sure mm-hmm and you
know shoo he quit drinking a while ago
it looks like he was getting in shape
but he's definitely slammed the bottle
right there before us
and that sounds like and I mean I'm not
saying this to be fun but it sounds like
he has brain damage some measure of
brain damage from all the head injuries
I don't know it also has a great memory
though yeah he has a great he really has
a fire memory you bring up any little
detail of our relationship over the
years right but he said he fell out of a
window a skylight and landed on his head
and then he also got a serious head
damage when he was on tour in the
military mm-hmm and falling off a truck
fell off a truck and they wanted to send
him home but he wanted to keep stirring
that [ __ ] on fire and then he was that a
rock under crash oh and he was in a
helicopter crash and then when he was
showing the head scar he also said his
stepfather threw him into a wall or
something so the guy has sustained a lot
of head injuries yeah a lot of head
injuries because you know he unlike a
very bright and I want to say like
quick-witted individual but I think from
a lot of drug use and hand injuries
he's turned he's morphed into what we
know now Noah's shoenice but nice he is
nice yeah he came he certainly can be
Wow
I wonder really what well I'm feel
blessed I mean that rhesus lamb was
incredible though I'm just I'm so happy
and thankful there's some reason that
seems harder than like a whole bottle of
vodka yeah for him [ __ ] is like water
six slamming a bottled water that rhesus
was the hardest thing I ever saw
oh we almost did an hour dance said okay
great Wow well guys shoenice is on he's
on
what is it called cameo cameo let's make
sure that he can stay in motel five as
long as he needs and he's also on
YouTube I don't know what his YouTube is
though he said he wanted five thousand
subs but I don't know he changes his
YouTube channel every week what's his
man what is his main YouTube channel
damn the most recent one he seems to
always be uploading on is called
shoenice official channel he's got a
hundred K subscribers on it oh really
let's take one for K no yeah you a nice
official channel I guess he posted a
video oh I don't have the screen of 2022
big things alright oh you can switch the
input on the TV back over to yours if
you want the screen back yeah let's do
that
yeah one hour ago h3 shoenice a long
awaited collab 15 seconds try now Ethan
guys take it easy I'm about five minutes
away from being on h3 h3 podcast if you
never heard of them subscribe now
because you'll never hear a story told
like this mm-hmm
it wasn't that true well that's it I
mean I had I mean there's no better way
to end the show than that I mean yeah
how else do we how else do we it left my
wait so many mixed emotions it's well I
wanted to ask more but he doesn't he
didn't really want to get home with his
family on his son some really sad yeah
deep deep
yeah and I have no idea what's really
going on with them but it sounded rough
I'm like I don't know sounds kind of
lonely but he does have a dog sir that's
cool yeah well who really knows what
goes on over at shoenice headquarters
but we thank him for coming on the show
and opening his his life to us from this
you know hmm what I was wondering is
that a meal for shoenice the Reese's hit
unless he puked it all out and we didn't
get that last game he does that guys so
many questions for sure well we'll have
to get part two we'll see I think it was
fascinating yeah I was intrigued that
was captivated do you think that I would
be a good Batman to him being the Joker
yeah I would watch that I know it's not
be awesome directed by Tommy wise oh I
guess that's it huh I guess so well
thank you guys for watching
mm-hmm I might replace you with shoenice
that's okay I can't understand that he's
very entertaining replace dad who shoot
ice that year guys's jobs are safe help
him out I think he needs it more than me
mmm I'm sweet I'm rather yeah I don't
know yeah but I'm happy with it you know
I am I do feel blessed that cameo is
probably the best birthday gift
apologies Ethan you did get me some good
gifts but no pretty good I like the way
he framed it like I like you gotyou that
was nice Oh stuff so we'll be back on
Friday and do we have what do we have
any guests lined up Daniel just good
old-fashioned times my dudes
okay we always say Friday but we don't
postal Saturday that's true nothing on
this show makes any sense yeah that's
true yeah we record on Friday we post
Saturday morning as this is recorded on
Tuesday and will be posted on Wednesday
morning you know what's weird too is
that we're gonna pause this and then
we're gonna go record the first part
yeah
telling the illusion man it's the band
of the show nobody watched this don't
tell anyone if you watch this deep say
wow I can't believe Ethan has lost so
much weight he looks incredible the
intermittent fasting windows really
seems to be working and the vegetarian
lifestyle is a great system that you
developed here because you really don't
remember that you asked him yet say that
and then and I didn't even fall out of a
skylight on my head it's a great
motivational yeah thing I do think that
you are losing weight but I will
actually don't want to say anything so
forget about what I just said
okay forgotten shoenice okay all right
guys we'll see you on Friday thank you
so much God bless thank you for watching
shoenice again thank
[Music]